FEDERAL LEADERSHIP WE’RE SEEING.
STEVE: WELL, EARLIER THIS HOUR,
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS,
RIGHT THERE, ON THE SHOW EXPLAIN
ING HIS DECISION TO SEND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO HELP
OUT AT THE BORDERS IN TEXAS AND
ARIZONA.
TEXAS, REPUBLICAN SENATOR TED
CRUZ, SITS ON THE BORDER
SECURITY AND IMMIGRATION
SUBCOMMITTEE AND JOINS US RIGHT
NOW FROM ORLANDO, FLORIDA WE’LL
TALK ABOUT THAT AND WHY HE’S
DOWN THERE IN A MOMENT BUT FIRST
, SENATOR, YOU KNOW, IT’S A
SAD COMMENTARY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT PATROLLING OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER AND NOW, THE
STATES HAVE GOT TO HELP EACH
OTHER, BECAUSE GOVERNOR ABBOTT
SAID WE NEED HELP, AND NOW,
STATES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE SENDING PEOPLE TO YOUR STATE
, BECAUSE IT’S A MESS.
>> WELL, IT IS, AND IT IS A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL ADVOCATION BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
QUITE SIMPLY NOT DOING THEIR JOB
AND REFUSING TO ENFORCE THE LAW
AND THEY’VE CREATED AN UN
MITIGATED CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO I TOOK 19
SENATORS DOWN TO THE BORDER TO
SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING
AND I’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER MANY
MANY TIMES.
IT IS WORSE THAN IT HAS EVER
BEEN.
WE HAD JUST, LAST MONTH, OVER
180,000 PEOPLE CROSS ILLEGALLY,
LAST MONTH.
WE’RE ON PACE FOR 2 MILLION
PEOPLE TO CROSS ILLEGALLY, AND
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS HAVE
ZERO INTENTION OF DOING ANYTHING
THAT’S WHY THEY WON’T GO TO THE
BORDER.
KAMALA AT THIS POINT IT’S
ALMOST LIKE A COMEDY SHOW.
SHE’S SO TERRIFIED IT REMINDS ME
OF THAT OLD SHOW WHEREIN THE
WORLD IS CARMEN SAN DIEGO.
SHE’LL GO EVERYWHERE EXCEPT THE
BORDER, BECAUSE SHE’S AFRAID
OF WHAT’S GOING ON DOWN THERE
AND THEY HAVE NO SOLUTIONS.
STEVE: SHE HASN’T BEEN TO EUROPE
EITHER I HEAR AND THEN SHE
LAUGHED.
>> [LAUGHTER]
STUSHIES LAUGHING IT OFF.
WHAT’S INTERESTING IS BECAUSE
IT’S SUCH A MESS DOWN THERE, ITS
BEEN ANNOUNCED BY THE GOVERNOR,
THAT HE’S PUT A DOWN PAYMENT OF
$250 MILLION ON HAVING THE STATE
OF FLORIDA FINANCE THE WALL.
>> YUP.
LOOK, I THINK IT IS A VERY GOOD
THING THAT WE’RE SEEING STATES
STEPPING UP.
WE’RE GLAD TO ALWAYS WELCOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHETHER FROM FLORIDA
OR  OTHER STATES TO COME TO
TEXAS.
THE STATE OF TEXAS HAS BEEN
LEADING WHEN IT COMES TO
SECURING THE BORDER FOR A LONG
TIME.
I’M GLAD THAT WE SEE THE
GOVERNOR AND STATE
LEGISLATURE INVESTING AND
FINISHING THE BORDER WALL, BUT
FOR YEARS WE’VE HAD TEXAS,
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS PATROLLING THE BORDER.
I’VE BEEN OUT ON THEM AND I TELL
YOU, YOU KNOW WHAT’S CRAZY?
THE TEXAS DPS HAS BETTER
EQUIPMENT THAN THE FEDS.
THEIR BOATS ARE BETTER, PLANES
ARE BETTER.
I’VE BEEN UP IN THE  DPS PLANE
WITH INCREDIBLE INFARED
TECHNOLOGY WHERE YOU CAN GO
EIGHT MILES AWAY AND UP IN THE
AIR AND THERE ARE TWO OR
THREE COYOTES, THERE’S A GROUP
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THEY ARE
GETTING READY TO SMUGGLE ACROSS
AND WHAT THEY DO IS CALL THE
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND SAY ALL RIGHT THEY
ARE CROSSING RIGHT HERE AND WHEN
YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB, THEY CAN
STOP AND INTERCEPT THEM.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO IT, AND THAT’S IT
RIGHT THERE.
NOW, YOU ARE IN A HALL RIGHT NOW
, IN ORLANDO, BECAUSE COMING
UP AT 11:00 THIS MORNING YOU ARE
SPEAKING AT THE FAITH AND
FREEDOM COALITION’S ROAD TO
MAJORITY CONFERENCE, WHICH IS
STREAMING THIS WEEKEND, ON FOX
NATION, FOR FOX NATION
SUBSCRIBERS.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT, SENATOR?
>> WELL, I’M GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT THE NEED TO DEFEND
AMERICA, THAT WE’RE SEEING AN
ASSAULT ON OUR FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES, WE’RE
SEEING AN ASSAULT ON OUR
CONSTITUTION AND BILL OF RIGHTS
AND AN ASSAULT ON OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS AND THE PRINCIPLES THAT
BUILT AMERICA.
WE’RE SEEING AN ASSAULT ON OUR
SOVEREIGNTY WITH THE BORDER NOT
BEING DEFENDED AND TODAY, MY
REMARKS ARE REALLY A CALL FOR
AMERICAN REVIVAL.
A CALL FOR US TO STAND UP AND
DEFEND OUR NATION.
THERE ARE ANGRY FORCES ON THE
LEFT THAT WANT TO TEAR DOWN
ALL OF THE PILLARS OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY AND WE’VE GOT TO
ANSWER THE CALL AND WE’VE GOT TO
STAND UP AND DEFEND THIS GREAT
NATION.
STRATEGIST WELL YOU’VE GOT A
BUSY DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR